throughout her reign the queen has
placed
and continues to place
the greatest importance
on the common friendship
humanity and values that all of us share
in this room not despite
but because of the diversity the
commonwealth represents
and i know how grateful she is that
in recognition
of her majesties and stinting service to
our commonwealth family
all commonwealth member states have
announced
that they have now committed themselves
to the queen's commonwealth canopy
i treasure the friendships we have built
over these past 70 years
and look forward
to their deepening in the years ahead
as we build back from the pandemic
that has devastated so many lives
as we respond to climate change and
biodiversity loss
that threatens our very existence
and as we see lives destroyed
by the unattenuated aggression
of violent forces
such friendships
are more important than ever
i take heart from the fact that working
together with urgent intent
there is a path to build a future for
humanity that is sustainable prosperous
and just
our commonwealth family is and will
always remain
a free association
of independent self-governing nations
we meet and talk
as
equals sharing our knowledge and
experience
for the betterment of all citizens of
the commonwealth
and indeed the wider world
the commonwealth contains
within it
countries
that have had constitutional
relationships
with my family
some that continue to do so
and increasingly those
that have had none
i want to say clearly as i have said
before
that each member's constitutional
arrangement
as republic or monarchy
is purely a matter for each member
country to decide
the benefit of long life
brings me the experience that
arrangements such as these
can change calmly and without rancor
but as i said in barbados last november
we should never forget
the things which do not change
the close and trusted partnership
between
commonwealth members
our common values and shared goals
and perhaps most importantly
the strong and enduring connections
between the peoples of the commonwealth
which strengthen us all
these shared
values goals and friendships
transcend the ties
of shared history
as we saw in welcoming mozambique
and rwanda to this great family of
nations
and now coming to rwanda for the first
time
visiting the genocide memorial and
speaking to survivors
i have been overwhelmed by the
resilience grace
and determination of the rwandan people
today rwanda
upholds so much that is extraordinary
as a center for innovation
a world leader in women's empowerment
a growing hub for the green economy
and a commitment to a united future
as leaders
you consider how to define and
strengthen
our own commitment to common purpose
and i would only offer you the view that
our commonwealth family of some of the
world's most vulnerable
and some of the world's wealthiest
nations
has the ability
indeed the obligation
to be a force for
global public good
why else
ladies and gentlemen would an increasing
number of countries want to join this
association
in the diversity of the 2.6 billion
people on whose behalf you speak
comes great strength
which you can use for instance to speak
up for the values which bind us
to invest in a rapid transition to a
sustainable future
and to create opportunities for our
young people
i believe that the commonwealth is
uniquely positioned to achieve such
positive change in our world
and in speaking to you
over the years i know you agree
indeed i can only applaud the focus you
are bringing to supporting youth
business and civil society not least to
the commonwealth professional
associations of judges teachers and
midwives to name but three
i know the importance you attach to
ensuring that support reaches the
developing world
and how important is the work you are
undertaking to develop new approaches
which take account
of climate vulnerability
to enable the better channeling of
development assistance
i was also greatly heartened at
yesterday's business forum
to see commonwealth leaders and global
ceos
including from my sustainable markets
initiative
identifying practical solutions to these
vital challenges
to achieve this potential good however
and to unlock the power of our common
future
we must also acknowledge the wrongs
which have shaped our past
many of those wrongs belong to an
earlier age with different
and in some ways lesser values
by working together
we are building a new
and enduring friendship
in canada recently my wife
and i were deeply touched
to meet many of those engaged in the
ongoing process of reconciliation
indigenous and non-indigenous peoples
reflecting honestly
and openly on one of the darkest aspects
of history
as challenging as that conversation can
be
people across canada are approaching it
with courage and unwavering commitment
determined to lay a foundation of
respect and understanding upon which a
better future can be built
it seems to me
that there are lessons in this for our
commonwealth family
for while we strive together for peace
prosperity and democracy
i want to acknowledge that the roots
of our contemporary association
run deep into the most painful period of
our history
i cannot describe the depths
of my personal sorrow at the suffering
of so many
as i continue to deepen my own
understanding of slavery's enduring
impact
if we are
to forge
a common future that benefits all our
citizens
we too must find ways
new ways to acknowledge our past
quite simply this is a conversation
whose time has come
your excellencies
conversations start with listening
and as the queen said at our last
meeting the commonwealth has always been
and remains
a global association
which believes in the tangible benefits
that flow
from exchanging ideas and experiences
and respecting each other's point of
view
our ingenuity knowledge and ideas our
courage and determination
are truly our common wealth
by unlocking our potential we can build
a future in which all our people have a
stake
ensuring that our commonwealth charter
represents not just words on a page
but the lived experience of all
and in so doing
we will equip
our children and grandchildren to be
agents of a better future
your excellencies if we are to leave the
world better than we found it
and that is our duty and our privilege
we must be bold with our ambition
decisive with our actions
and united in our effort
in this mission i know
her majesty the queen stands with us all